you don't need a gym membership to get
into amazing shape
because you can sneak in
no you don't need a gym at all
in fact your gym might very well be
holding you back
in order to use the fullest potential of
your body that means your speed agility
strength and power
it just doesn't make sense to shut
yourself in a small crowded room
standing on the spot curling or sitting
patiently waiting for the squat rack is
hardly that much better than sitting at
the office
and a huge thank you to nordvpn for
sponsoring this video
i always think that the best workouts
should take up space you should be
running jumping climbing throwing
pulling crawling rolling and lifting i'm
not just talking about max strength then
i'm talking about actual performance
that challenges a variety of different
capacities within a single workout this
is what real fitness is about to me
looking and feeling good happen to be
nice byproducts of this general fitness
so start training with medicine balls
kettlebells sandbags and battle ropes
jump onto a box get outside into open
fields or just your own garden and if
you don't have access to those things
try filling a backpack with heavy items
or find a big log you can use you can
even push your car and if you can't do
that you can still crawl sprint skip run
and train with your own body weight and
you can even just train in your living
room in fact for a huge number of people
simply performing reps of push-ups
squats and pull-ups to failure will make
a huge difference these are movements
that most people can do and they're hard
to get wrong and if you can't do them
find easier variations like push-ups
against a wall or assisted pull-ups
safer in the way then use that to your
advantage get your feet up on it and do
some decline push-ups
trust me if you regularly perform these
three movements with high intensity say
three to five times per week you will
see results within months you'll be
doing tens or even hundreds of push-ups
in a single workout this will come with
improvements in your max strength your
physique and your energy levels this is
literally all you need as so many
prisoner workouts have shown us if you
want to venture further as you get
stronger you can try your movements that
require more strength whether that means
archer push-ups dips or weighted
pull-ups
few things will work your upper body
like an l-sit into handstand press [ __ ]
squats glute bridges split squats and
more can really work the legs
or perhaps buy some rings or a rope to
climb if you want to get advanced you
can include calisthenics skills like
planche or handstand push-up training
planche is a gigantic challenge that
less than one percent of the trained
population will likely achieve there is
no ceiling to what you can accomplish
with just your own body weight
start to explore more planes of motion
too frontal and transverse move side to
side twist your body hit those neglected
areas like your grip and your straight
arm strength
but for when you're not topless running
around fields in the freezing cold
there's the web so i'd like to take this
moment to say thank you once again to
this video's sponsor nordvpn nordvpn is
a vpn or a virtual private network
in a nutshell it's a tool that lets you
hide your ip address and keep your data
private while surfing the web nerdy
wells won't be able to find out who you
are or where you're located and nor will
they be able to see the data you're
sending and because you're interacting
with the web via a nordvpn server that
means you can choose any location to
browse from this means you can stream
films and tv shows that wouldn't
regularly be available in your region
that means more anime superheroes and
action films to inspire and motivate
your workouts the best part is that this
won't bring your internet speeds down to
a crawl nordvpn is actually the very
fastest vpn on the market as confirmed
by the latest speed tests your data is
valuable and technology should be a
liberating and empowering tool so if you
want to browse safely quickly and with
control over how you're seen on the web
consider signing up for nordvpn today
and this holiday if you go to
nordvpn.com forward slash the bioneer
you'll also get a massive discount on a
two-year plan plus one additional month
and it will help me out in a big way too
there's a link to that in the
description down below and thank you so
much for your support guys i hugely
appreciate the congratulations on the
last sponsored video and again a massive
thank you to nordvpn for sponsoring this
one
so why is it that so many people feel
lost without a gym one answer is
probably the difficulty of training
using very heavy weights minus a squat
rack and the convenience of measuring
progress when you have a long row of
dumbbells to work with
firstly there's nothing to stop you from
setting up a squat rack at home
but assuming that's not viable for you
there are plenty of ways to develop a
lot of strength with less weight split
squat with two 20 30 or 40 kilogram
dumbbells and there's no need to lift
something onto your shoulders
and you'll be building single leg
strength for greater athleticism and
stability
it is possible to build strength and
size using 50 or even less of your one
rep max it just takes longer and favors
strength endurance a little which isn't
such a bad thing if you're moving
powerfully and if you go to failure you
will challenge all of your motor units
and all of your muscle fibers and while
it's harder to track as long as you're
pushing hard to failure every time
you'll keep improving
other movements that put you at more of
a mechanical disadvantage require far
less weight and if you're interested in
power and speed the advice is to add no
more than 30 of your body weight
otherwise you become too slow
in fact with just a few tools or light
weights you can genuinely target every
single muscle group energy system and
plane of motion and to prove it i've
included a full body workout routine in
the description below that hits nearly
everything the average joe could want in
one short workout with minimal equipment
the link will take you to my website
where it's completely free to download
with no need to sign up
just a little thank you from me
if you're able to use both types of
training then put those movements that
are more strength and skill oriented at
the start of the workout and place those
movements that are safer and challenge
endurance towards the end
experiment and try different challenges
to keep your body guessing
you'll build strength while also
increasing work capacity energy and the
appearance of a lean physique and you'll
be far more athletic than the average
gym bro
it's not optimal if your power lifts are
sure but for everyone else what you lose
in a little strength you'll gain in
speed coordination power and all-round
athleticism you'll have fewer gaps in
your strength you'll be much fitter
while still being extremely strong
and to be clear i'm not saying that gyms
are bad i'm saying that if you can't
access the gym or don't want to you can
still more than achieve most of your
fitness goals and for most everyone else
the gym works best as a component of
your training as just one of many
settings if you've spent a lot of time
statically squatting or pressing getting
out of the gym will let you start
applying that strength and power in a
more dynamic setting
and of course being able to train from
home means no commute this alone is
enough to drastically increase adherence
for many people starting out if you
can't bring yourself to train just do
one set of squats in front of the tv
it's better than nothing
better yet this might mean that you can
train more than once a day take more
opportunities to move work on new skills
and techniques or improve mobility if
you only associate movement with working
out and you only associate working out
with the gym you're fighting an uphill
battle you're essentially trying to undo
13 hours of sitting with one hour of
training
we should be moving throughout the day
start to do this and you'll feel better
than ever
you don't need the gym
in fact it may be holding you back
[Music]
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share around
that would help me out immensely and
subscribe of course for more like this
actually if you're a regular viewer and
you subscribe that's one of the biggest
things you can do to help the channel
grow
if you're looking for more ways to train
outside the gym and test yourself beyond
the normal moveset you might enjoy my
ebook and training program super
functional training
included in that package is a specific
minimal equipment routine especially for
these kinds of scenarios or check out my
print book functional training and
beyond on amazon to learn about
functional training in general
do you guys rely on the gym how did
quarantine change the way that you work
out
thanks so much for watching this one
guys i hugely appreciate it
and bye for now
you